[Musique]
l'arrivée d'internet a bouleversé bien
des aspects de nos vies et le rapport à
notre santé en fait partie un symptôme
un malaise une douleur un doute de
l'inquiétude est notre premier réflexe
est souvent de se tourner vers un moteur
de recherche et c'est là où les choses
peuvent déraper quand l'hypocondrie fait
place à la cyber caudry
marie perles la super qu'andris dans un
contexte de pandémie c'est un alliage
assez particulier oui oui ça ça va très
bien ensemble il ya déjà eu quelques
publications scientifiques sur le sujet
et oui oui à certaines de ces
publications lockheed antifit les remet
à la cyber caudry comme un effet
secondaire de la pan ding un effet
secondaire qui est plus fréquent chez
ceux qui utilisent les médias sociaux
comme principale source d'information
est-ce qu'on est sur ebay ça parce qu'il
ya un lien quand même assez étroit avec
l'anxiété bon on rappelle un petit peu
ce que c'est la cyber caudry ya pas de
définition officielle de ça mais on
pourrait la définir dans le fond comme
une forme de désinformation
conscrée soi même il dont on est la
principale victime en cherchant de
manière compulsive à s'auto
diagnostiquer
auto diagnostic et ses symptômes sur
internet puis quand je dis qu'il ya un
lien étroit avec l'anxiété c'est un peu
comme sa petite cousine l'hypocondrie on
cherche l'info dans le but calmer
l'anxiété mais dans le fond on finit par
l'alimenter et évidemment la pandémie
l'eau je voulais revenir six est une
période particulièrement anxiogène que
tous les travaux laissez les travailler
exactement quand on est chez soi dans
son petit cocon seul avec son ordinateur
donc le contexte est favorable pour se
mettre à multiplier les recherches en
ligne mais seuls des recherches en ligne
quand on a un symptôme qui nous inquiète
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui mais
c'est pas n'importe qui qui
nécessairement cyber condrieu non c'est
va pâtir de camp lui le record c'est
difficile à dire parce que la cyber
conduit fait pas partie du des sm5 la
fameuse bible de référence des troubles
de santé mentale
donc il ya pas de consensus combien
temps d'établir des critères
diagnostiques
pas d'estimations précises du
pourcentage de la population qui est
affectée non plus il ya quand même un
outil d'évaluation qui a été publié en
2014 le saiper koudria so british que
ces espèces le test en brouillant globe
les cinq principales dimensions de la
super conduit à savoir l'aspect
compulsif et quel point ça affecte les
activités de la vie quotidienne la
détresse le caractère excessif la quête
de réassurance dans ton ce qu'on veut
c'est être rassurés qu'en fait cela et
aussi la méfiance envers le personnel de
la santé ça vient ça vient souvent avec
si je donne un exemple concret mettons
que d'une contraction musculaire
involontaire l'eau dans les doigts comme
ça arrive parfois ensemble sur internet
contraction involontaire
doit ou mieux encore dans le fond si on
va pas vraiment plus de résultats le
puits vraiment aller se perdre dans les
dédales du web ont enfin l'anglais ouais
donc
singer switching et là avant même de
lancer la recherche
on nous suggère
finger switching parkinson donc bon là
déjà ça nous joue dans la tête un petit
peu mais tant qu'on clique juste finger
switching
là vraiment on voit tous les résultats
qui s'affichent et on découvre que ça
pourrait aussi bien être la maladie de
huntington la sclérose en plaques ou
pourquoi pas la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique maladie neurodégénérative
au fur et à mesure où on clique source
lien loeb on se découvre de nouveaux
symptômes ont fait de nouvelles
recherches et le ont fini par
complètement se perdent et au foie il ya
deux moteurs à ce cycle infernal
l'intolérance à l'incertitude et le
besoin d'être rassuré dans le fond c'est
vraiment ça lorsque ces personnes leur
recherche s'est dissipée leur anxiété se
convaincre que rien de grave qui les
menacent puis se disent qu'ils vont
arrêter quand ils vont finir par le
trouver cet apaisement là sauf
qu'évidemment par définition l'abondance
la diversité des informations qu'on
trouve sur internet vont faire que cette
certitude la voit jamais venir et on
continue à chercher puisque qui nous
décrit marie pierre s'est pas
entièrement nouveau j'imagine que ça
correspond au sart monde ou à peu près à
la naissance d'internet non bah oui on
peut penser que la cyber qu'on dit
existe depuis que le préfixe cyber est
entré dans le langage courant mais on en
parle beaucoup plus je tirais depuis
2008 c'est l'année où il ya eu la
publication d'une vaste étude sur le
sujet par des chercheurs de microsoft
qui se sont intéressés aux comportements
en ligne d'un million d'internautes au
contenu de dizaines de millions de pages
web et qui ont aussi posé des questions
à 515 employés de l'entreprise et leur
but c'est vraiment de comprendre les
facteurs qui contribuent à l escalade de
l'inquiétude quand on se met à faire des
recherches liées à la santé en ligne
mais parmi les conclusions les plus
intéressantes il ya le fait qu'à peu
près le tiers des internautes qui se
lancent dans une recherche élaboré à
connotation médical disons ils ont
tendance à escalader et c'est vraiment
le terme que les chercheurs d'emploi
escalettes
c'est à dire que la recherche d'un
symptôme assez banal initial va finir
par se métamorphoser en recherche sur
quelque chose de beaucoup plus sérieux
est un exemple les chercheurs dont dix
ont une recherche qui commence par mal
de tête vont mener à une page qu'on va
lire et qui vont nous pousser à faire
une recherche mal de tête et tu meurs
puis de fil en aiguille on finit par
faire une recherche sur les traitements
des tumeurs au cerveau
un des gros pièges en tout cas selon les
auteurs c'est l'idée fausse selon
laquelle les résultats les plus
pertinents sont ceux qui sortent en
premier ça va pousser plusieurs à
consulter seulement les premiers
résultats qui s'affichent et qui peuvent
aussi bien nous parler de tumeurs au
cerveau que d'un manque de caféine alors
qu'on s'entend là le risque de souffrir
d'une tumeur au cerveau est quand même
moins élevé que celui d'expérimenter
momentanément un petit ouvrage halak a
fait tout ce qu'on décrit marie pierre
il ya beaucoup d'aspects négatifs mais
il n'ya pas que du négatif dans toujours
non c'est important quand même
d'insister là dessus il ya même une
étude assez récente qui va à
contre-courant de la réputation négative
de l'autodiagnostic sur internet
oui c'est inévitable après un petit
google il ya des patients panique qui
vont se ruer chez leur médecin mais ce
serait loin d'être des patients qui sont
représentatifs de toute la population
selon cette étude la même que la
recherche
sur internet de symptômes qu'on
expérimente le pour rien nous rendre
meilleurs pour diagnostiquer plusieurs
problèmes mais pas forcément toujours
nous inciter à imaginer le p